[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité avec la réforme
des retraites et les mobilisations qui
se poursuivent une évolution se fait
jour dans le paysage social agité de
notre pays la Côte des syndicats
représentatifs n'en finit pas de grimper
conséquences les adhésions se
multiplient depuis le début de l'année
explication de nos confrères de Vosges
télévision dans un instant des
parachutistes comme s'il en pleuvait La
Dépêche du Midi nos confrères nous
dévoilera les coulisses de l'exercice
militaire Orion une opération inédite
par son ampleur dont l'objectif est de
préparer l'armée aux enjeux d'une guerre
moderne vous verrez et puis un sport
impressionnant en plein développement le
premier tournoi de MMA était organisé il
y a quelques jours encore l'occasion de
promouvoir cette pratique spectaculaire
des images de télépasis en fin de
journal et puis un chantier aussi
historique que monumental augmente la
cathédrale Saint-Julien en pleine
restauration la rédaction de lmtvart n'a
pas hésité à prendre de la hauteur pour
suivre ses travaux faits de patience et
de détails
maison débute donc ce journal avec
l'actualité sociale est toujours et les
manifestations qui se poursuivent contre
la réforme des retraites un peu partout
dans le pays près de deux mois après le
début du mouvement la mobilisation reste
élevée et semble profiter au syndicat
uni ceux-ci voit leur rend se gonfler et
les adhésions se multiplient c'est le
cas notamment dans le département des
Vosges explications et chiffres
d'Aurélie Colombelles de Titan boiteux
pour rejeter télévision
c'est une conséquence des fortes
mobilisations sociales de ces dernières
semaines l'intersyndicale reste unie et
les syndicats attirent de nouveaux
adhérents une augmentation vérifiée au
niveau national encore plus nette dans
notre département une satisfaction dans
les Vosges une progression de 1er
janvier aujourd'hui de 40%. alors que au
niveau national on a une progression de
30%. en ce qui concerne les indépendants
les isolés c'est plus d'une centaine
d'adhérents supplémentaires depuis le
début de l'année en France seul un
salarié sur 10 et syndiqué pourcentage à
la baisse depuis 20 ans cette nouvelle
dynamique est donc un signe positif pour
les syndicats des adhésions qui se font
en partie les jours de manifestations la
fréquentation des sites Internet ont
aussi progressé à cela plusieurs
analyses en premier lieu une lutte qui
fédère c'est surprenant parce que ça a
un cool adhésion c'est une cotisation
tous les mois avec l'inflation on peut
imaginer que ça peut être un frein et
pourtant ils adhèrent à cela
s'ajouteraient les faits gilets
jaunes il y avait conduit on s'en
souvient à des déborde
ments actuels de structurer et pacifique
bien sûr des mouvements de lutte ça a
toujours été le cas ont toujours amené
quand même une voilà ben voilà un autre
gars parle de salariat une force
complémentaire à l'heure des élections
des représentants en entreprise et des
négociations salariales d'autant plus
apres du fait de l'inflation mais pour
la CFDT le premier syndicat du
département l'augmentation du nombre
d'adhésions s'est enclenché depuis
plusieurs mois on a une progression en
2022 par rapport à 2021 de 47%. alors on
sort d'une crise sanitaire on va dire on
revie les salariés revivent sont sur
place les équipes syndicales aussi le
message de l'Inter syndical de cette
unité en tout cas et de cette entente
profite je pense à toutes les
organisations syndicales les
mobilisations contre la réforme des
retraites se poursuivent avec à la clé
peut-être de nouveaux engagements
voilà et comme lors de chaque
rassemblement les opposants à la réforme
des retraites font preuve d'imagination
symboles d'expression par excellence la
pancarte est devenue un outil
indispensable pour exprimer son opinion
entre humour et message politique
l'inspiration est souvent au rendez-vous
voici quelques exemples avec ce sujet de
vie Occitanie regardez
elles sont souvent remplies d'humour
originales quelquefois subtiles voire
grossière mais elle ne laisse pas
indifférent elles se sont les pancarres
des manifestants contre la réforme des
retraites point commun elles ont
l'avantage de délivrer un message clair
mais le message c'est
que en réalité c'est que il donne en
riches ils prennent tout au pauvre voilà
je pense que si les richesses étaient
partagées les gens seraient d'accord
pour faire des efforts mais là dans la
situation actuelle c'est juste un
dessert en fait de demander à des gens
qui sont ouvriers et qui pensent partir
dans quelques années de travailler plus
quand il y a des gens qui n'arriveront
jamais à dépenser tout ce qu'ils
amassent et j'ai des petits pouces comme
ça depuis ce matin donc ça les fait rire
ça leur parle je pense qu'ils sont
d'accord avec le message un message qui
s'accorde dans toutes les villes de la
région sur l'idée qu'un départ à la
retraite à 64 ans et synonyme de pied
dans la tombe c'est la mise en bière
prématurée
l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans surtout si
on a commencé de bonheur c'est très
compliqué certaines plus optimistes
gardent l'espoir qui fait vivre et
préfère penser à leurs petits-enfants on
souhaite que que le meilleur pour eux
mais surtout que nous on puisse en
profiter deux ans au lieu de travailler
deux heures de plus reste à savoir si
c'est pancarte seront vus de Paris avec
l'idée là aussi majoritairement partagé
que la réforme est brutale
dans le reste de l'actualité cette
semaine on retiendra aussi l'hommage
national rendu à Gisèle à limite dans le
cadre de la Journée internationale des
droits des femmes le 8 mars dernier
l'avocate est militante décédée en 2020
c'était notamment fait connaître pour
son combat contre la dépénalisation de
l'avortement lors du procès de Bobigny
il y a maintenant 50 ans un événement
majeur pour la société mise en scène
actuellement dans une adaptation
théâtrale comme vous le voyez sur ces
images 4 représentations des plaidoiries
de l'époque au profit du fond de
dotation barreau de Paris solidarité
regardez cet extrait
la première fois que Marie-Claire a un
rapport sexuel
est forcément c'est unique fois elle
tombe enceinte
Monsieur le Procureur
va nous dire qu'il est sceptique il nous
dit que puisque Marie-Claire n'a pas
précisé au cours de l'instruction
qu'elle avait été brutalisée c'est que
vraisemblablement elle n'avait pas du
l'être
du talent et du mérite encore au féminin
dans ce journal direction Bordeaux à
présent dans la petite cuisine d'Oxana
crétu cette chef d'origine moldave est
l'une des rares femmes à la tête d'un
restaurant gastronomique en Gironde une
carrière derrière les fourneaux qui
était pourtant loin d'être évidente pour
elle son portrait est signé Diane
douillet pour TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest
son ancre une cuisine d'à peine 6 mètres
carrés qu'elle partage avec Milan son
second
pour la fille pas pour la poupée c'est
juste pour la taille de la cuisine c'est
là aussi coxana crétu réalise au
quotidien la prouesse d'élaborée des
menus gastronomiques en deux à sept ans
inspiré de ses origines moldaves en gare
forestier et donc mon enfant c'est
beaucoup lié à des choses enfin que je
retrouve sans faire exprès dans ma
cuisine aujourd'hui l'argousier ou
encore l'amande pour sublimer des plats
que cette ancienne designer veut aussi
bon qu'esthétique une reconversion oui
mais une quête de sens avant tout
j'étais d'abord maman et ensuite j'ai eu
un gros stress de ne pas lui laisser
quelque chose d'important dans sa vie et
j'ai décidé de faire quelque chose qui
me plaît ok ça nacré tout a suivi des
formations en cuisine mais se présentent
plutôt comme une autodidacte audacieuse
les chefs beaucoup de temps dans une
cuisine chez quelqu'un chez un grand
d'habitude un grand chef moi j'ai juste
osé on va dire de faire les choses
différemment jouer des coups des seuicés
jusqu'au sommet de la gastronomie
française cela n'est pas la chef du
Cro-Magnon elle travaille dur pour un
jour prochain peut-être tutoyer les
étoiles du célèbre guider rouge Michelin
c'est quand même beaucoup de choses et
on n'y est pas encore donc on travaille
dur une récompense qui arriverait comme
la cerise sur le gâteau
allez sans transition intéressons-nous à
présent au développement de l'énergie
solaire en France au moins 13% de sa
production serait issue écoutez bien de
six agricoles de plus en plus
d'agriculteurs se laissent en effet
séduire par ses installations qui
peuvent couvrir leurs besoins et générer
un revenu supplémentaire bien sûr
reportage dans une exploitation bretonne
de Christophe boucher et de Caroline
chevrolier pour TVO la chaîne du groupe
télégramme en Bretagne
transformer un ancien poulailler en site
de production d'électricité c'est le
pari fait par cet éleveur laitier dans
le Morbihan sur le toit au sud comme au
nord des panneaux photovoltaïques qui
produisent 190
000 kilowatt-heure par an
l'équivalent de la consommation
électrique de 20 maisons le retour sur
investissement commence au bout de 12 à
14 ans mais l'intérêt pour cette
agriculteur est qu'un tel dispositif
demande peu d'entretien une fois
installé on met l'outil en place une
fois et ça produit durablement
95% de du travail qu'on doit fournir
c'est à la mise en place de
l'installation et après c'est 5% de
sérieux par la maintenance et autres
mais c'est très complémentaire au métier
d'agriculteur Laurent Moréac est l'un
des initiateurs de la péfa l'association
vise à accompagner depuis plus de 10 ans
les agriculteurs vers la production
d'électricité comme lui parce qu'elle
Chausset crois en ce développement au
sein de leur profession mais le photo ne
sera pas suffisant pour répondre à
l'objectif de l'État pour 2050 on doit
en gros multiplier par 8 à 10 la
puissance actuelle photovoltaïque qui
est installée donc c'est considérable et
toutes les toitures agricoles et autres
qui existent il suffiront pas et c'est
pour ça que cette essentiel que les
agriculteurs et la profession soit à la
manœuvre pour faire en sorte que ces
projets agricoles puissent être un outil
pour augmenter à la fois la performance
des cultures ou de l'élevage mais aussi
donc les performances économiques de
l'exploitation par un revenu
complémentaire
à l'origine association régionale et
désormais nationale face au prix de
l'électricité qui s'envole elle a vu son
nombre d'adhérents multiplié par deux en
un an passant de 250 à 500
voilà et il n'y a pas que les
exploitations agricoles qui peuvent
servir à produire de l'énergie solaire
les stades de foot aussi la preuve à
l'image avec ses 180 mètres carrés de
panneaux photovoltaïques installé à
Chambéry porté par une initiative
citoyenne ce nouvel équipement permettra
de couvrir la consommation électrique
annuelle de 35 personnes des images de
la rédaction de 8 monts blancs en Savoie
du soleil une bonne partie de l'année
l'île de la Martinique retrouve le
sourire en même temps que les touristes
près de trois ans après le début de la
covid-19 dans les restaurants les
commerces ou encore les hôtels la
fréquentation est identique à 2019 voir
supérieur une bonne nouvelle pour
l'économie locale reportage de Maxime Le
que pourvient à TV regardez
presque aucun centimètre carré de sable
disponible ce matin à la plage de lance
mi-temps ceci emblématique est pris
d'assaut par les touristes venus
profiter des plaisirs de la Martinique
pour la nourriture la plage le soleil
il y a des il y a des sites qui sont
magnifiques qu'est-ce qui vous plaît si
particulièrement
le soleil la mer surtout la température
de l'eau à quelques mètres de là ce
restaurateur considère même que la
fréquentation est identique à celle
d'avant 2020
[Musique]
des Allemands c'est mieux qu'avant si
les restaurants profitent de ce retour
du tourisme c'est aussi le cas pour
Marie qui enchaîne les locations de
scooter des mers
pour un s'élar gilet j'ai attaché les
jet-ski
et puis on est reparti
kayak ou encore pédalo c'est toute la
filière nautique qui se frotte les mains
donc avec les Croisiers
voilà donc ça fait plaisir de revoir
tout ça beau monde un retour des
touristes qui se vérifie également dans
les hôtels selon les représentants du
secteur le taux de remplissage pourrait
même dépasser celui de 2019 avec 90% de
taux d'occupation pour le mois de
février
puis en métropole aussi les touristes
sont de retour et parmi eux nos
meilleurs amis à quatre pattes sont
parfois des compagnons indispensables à
nos vacances néanmoins il n'est pas
toujours facile de faire du tourisme
avec son chien en Moselle Thionville et
la deuxième commune à être labellisée
tout rythme un kit de bienvenue qui
permet ainsi aux maîtres et maîtresses
de connaître les adresses favorables à
l'accueil de leur partenaire de vacances
une idée qui a du chien comme pu le
constater Jonathan de Vaucher pour
Moselle télévision regardez
visitez la France en compagnie de son
chien n'est pas toujours facile alors
depuis quelques jours l'Office de
Tourisme de Thionville propose des kits
d'accueil pour les animaux et leur
maître de passage dans la ville
aujourd'hui une quarantaine de villes
font partie de ce label tout tourisme en
effet en France plus de 6 voyageurs sur
10 en mène leurs animaux de compagnie en
vacances une initiative qui séduit
autant les résidents que les touristes
je fréquente le centre ville de
Thionville très régulièrement j'ai déjà
réfléchi ou est-ce que je peux m'arrêter
pour que le chien aille puisse boire
dans le pack est distribué aux visiteurs
des friandises un sac de propreté ou
encore un guide à des hôtels et
restaurants qui accueillent nos amis à
quatre pattes mais je pense que c'est
nous compagnons au quotidien il nous
donne et il nous apporte beaucoup c'est
une façon d'accueillir les gens et de
leur montrer quelque part qui les
animaux nos amis les animaux sont bien
bienvenue également dans les
établissements créer dans la ville de
Troyes en 2017 le label tout tourisme
permet d'offrir aux chiens tout le
confort que peuvent avoir les humains
avec plusieurs partenaires qui
n'hésitent pas à jouer le jeu on a déjà
créé des partenariats au sein du
centre-ville avec pour l'accueil pour
favoriser l'accueil des chiens
au centre-ville avec notamment l'Hôtel
du Parc et le restaurant Les Moulins
bleus c'est un petit biscuit de nez à la
fin du repas au maître qui viennent avec
leurs chiens en Moselle après Metz en
2022 Thionville et la deuxième ville a
proposé cette idée qui a du chien
allez des images spectaculaires
maintenant dans ce journal celle vous
allez le voir d'une évacuation plutôt
particulière d'un véhicule accidenté
dans la Loire faute d'accès cette
voiture qui a chuté de 60 mètres dans un
ravin annuels héliportée une opération
extraordinaire qui a nécessité la mise
en place de mesure de sécurité
exceptionnelles le véhicule complètement
endommagé a dû être coupé en deux pour
pouvoir être enlevé des images d'Anthony
verpillons pour TL7 la télévision de la
Loire et puis pour être tout à fait
complet sachez que le conducteur s'en
est sorti avec quelques côtes cassées
plus de peur que de mal donc
pas de voiture endommagée mais un ennemi
à neutraliser 300 parachutistes ont
participé il y a quelques jours à un
exercice militaire inédit par son
ampleur dans le Tarn-et-Garonne des
images impressionnantes que vous
découvrez à l'écran de nos partenaires
de la Dépêche du Midi une simulation
grandeur nature pour les forces armées
qui visent à reproduire un théâtre de
guerre écoutez ces quelques précisions
recueillies par Clément Gassi sur place
depuis des années 80 effectivement c'est
en tant que j'ai pas eu autant après
nous ce qui nous change c'est que quand
même énormément d'avions à disposition
et ça vous permet d'enchaîner les phases
de reprojection le 11ème brigade par
justice c'est faire donc un gros saut à
Castres une phase de combat 12 heures
pour se remettre en conditions et on
ressaute dans un endroit totalement
différent donc ici à qui on est en
conditions réelles on a les gilets par
balles avec les plaques les rations qui
vont bien l'armement qui va bien tout ce
qui va bien un exercice des armées qui
nous conduit à la rencontre de soldats
blessés à Marseille soigner notamment
grâce à la navigation pour penser des
blessures parfois invisibles prendre le
large peut s'avérer utile à bord d'un
voilier l'association 30 jours de maire
aide à la reconstruction des militaires
qu'elle soit physique ou psychologique
objectif reprendre confiance en soi par
la pratique de la voile explication au
micro de Charles louas du journal La
Marseillaise
c'est un sport qui est l'équipe et qui
est assez proche finalement de ce qui de
ce qui est demandé un soldat et
malheureusement quand un soldat est
blessé on le sort de son utile il se
trouve un peu tout seul et c'est parfois
un peu compliqué le fait de les mettre
ensemble sur un bateau et de les faire
participer à toutes les manœuvres et qui
doivent du coup réaliser ensemble à un
véritable c'est pour un retour un retour
à la cohésion à l'esprit de camaraderie
allez tout à fait autre chose à présent
20 kg par jour et par supermarché 10
millions de tonnes d'invendus termine
chaque année dans les poubelles de nos
magasins un problème autant social qui
écologique que tente de contrer depuis 8
ans un collectif grenoblois son nom les
glaneurs solidaires son objectif lutter
contre le gaspillage alimentaire en
faisant les courses directement dans les
poubelles un sujet de lina-bra de Dean
pour télécommande regardez
au total 5 équipes se sont constituées
ce jour-là objectif lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaire en récupérant les
denrées encore consommables dans les
poubelles des supermarchés depuis huit
ans la fratrie des glaneurs solidaires
grenoublots propose une alternative aux
associations qui exigent des revenus en
dessous de 700 euros pour être aidé ce
soir on a récupéré pas mal de légumes et
de yaourt et là on a aussi récupéré des
croissants des viennoiseries selon le
ministère de la transition écologique
les pertes et gaspillages alimentaires
représentent 10 millions de tonnes de
produits par an une valeur commerciale
estimée à 16 milliards d'euros deux
adultes avec trois enfants et chaque
semaine ça me permet de pouvoir faire
donc j'ai calculé environ entre 250 et
300 euros d'économie en course et après
chaque passage les membres du collectif
nettoie et remettent les bennes en place
nos actions se base sur de la
désobéissance civile sur de l'action
directe et non violente mais pour
empêcher les glaneurs certaines
enseignes ont leur technique ils mettent
des trucs en verre volontairement pour
blesser les les personnes qui
tenteraient de monter dans ce magasin il
y a eu un pacifié il y a eu des gens qui
ont foutu le bordel or ce n'était pas
nous alors depuis dans ce supermarché de
Fontaine les produits jetés sont
éventrés avec soin chaque aliment a été
transpercé d'un coup de cutter pourtant
depuis 2016 la loi garrot interdit les
pratiques de destruction d'aliments
encore consommables mais les glaneurs
réussissent quand même à récupérer
certains produits un butin qu'il partage
ensuite
les autres équipes de collecte tous ces
aliments qui auraient dû être jetés
serviront donc à nourrir des étudiants
personnes âgées travailleurs et classe
moyenne précaires personne en situation
de handicap la liste est longue autant
que le combat qu'il mène contre le
gaspillage alimentaire
voilà et puis se débarrasser d'un peu de
déchets alimentaires en échange de
quelques œufs frais voilà une initiative
bienvenue mais il y a 7 ans dans la
commune de bucan dans l'Oise au cœur de
ce village les 200 habitants peuvent se
fournir gratuitement en neuf contre
leurs épluchures de fruits et légumes ou
leur reste de produits laitiers autant
de déchets qui font le bonheur des
volailles et permettent aux habitants de
faire quelques économies des précisions
de Jérémie houblon pour weetv la chaîne
du Courrier Picard et de la Voix du Nord
3 fois par semaine et saut en main
Charline vient ici accomplir une bonne
action nourrir les poules de sa commune
des restes de manger du pain d'asmoule
c'est tout ce qui me reste dans
frigidaire parce que qu'on est deux donc
en fin de compte des fois il y a trois
mangés puis on laisse dans frigidaire et
puis je finis par les données comme ça
il y a pas de déchets dans la poubelle
pratique car au passage Charline en
profite pour ramasser gratuitement
quelques œufs frais
voilà c'est bon on va laisser pour les
autres un poulailler communal et
participatif une idée simple mais
efficace imaginée par la municipalité de
bucan il y a près de 7 ans l'employé
communal Metz dans la boîte aux lettres
et les gens quand ils amènent du déchet
aux poules et en compensation il
récupère des œufs 15 poules de réformes
occupent cette basse-cour de quoi faire
profiter les deux sans habitants d'une
dizaine de par jour c'est une économie
en moyenne 25 centimes d'euros de l'oeuf
et une solution bienvenue car en janvier
2024 chaque administré devra
obligatoirement trier ses déchets la
gestion d'un poulailler n'est pas de
tout repos il faut certes nourrir ses
résidentes mais aussi leur permettre de
se dégourdir les pattes et même là tout
est pensé pour rendre la tâche moins
pénible on a pu innover avec un cordage
et puis des bâtons de bois pour que les
gens puissent matin ouvrir ou alors
fermer
les poules à distance un seul de ses
gallinacées peut consommer 400 g de
déchets par jour cela peut sembler
dérisoire mais avec son poulailler une
année devrait suffire à la commune pour
revaloriser deux tonnes de biodéchets
allez un peu de sport en cette fin de
journée avec la pratique des arts
martiaux mixtes souvent désignés par le
sigle MMA qui poursuit son développement
partout en France il y a quelques jours
c'est la Corse qui accueillait son
premier tournoi de MMA pour l'occasion
cette combattants insulaires sont entrés
dans la cage suivi par les caméras de
télépaizées sur place image et réactions
récoltées par Marc-Antoine mucelli
c'est le premier événement encore de
mémoire fallait pas de louper et je
pense que le public est il a kiffé il y
avait du monde c'était super il y avait
des bons des bons adversaires moi j'ai
gagné mes deux combats donc je suis
super fier
[Musique]
la première du MMA encore c'est un
événement en détail ici à Bastia un
événement de taille oui cette première
étape de la MMA League amateur donc
voilà aujourd'hui on n'a pas pu boxer
pendant des années parce qu'on était
privé de MMA sur Lille et on était privé
de MMA aussi même sur le continent
puisque le MMA était pas autorisé en
France depuis 2020 c'est le cas on peut
boxer chez nous et aujourd'hui c'est la
première étape en Corse et nos
combattants sont contents de boxer c'est
c'est le top
allez on referme cette édition avec un
chantier impressionnant celui de la
cathédrale Saint-Julien au Mans des
travaux est allés sur plus d'un an et
qui permettront notamment la
restauration des vitraux et de la
maçonnerie de l'édifice Enzo Maubert
pour LM TV Sarthe a donné de sa personne
pour monter quelques échafaudages et
constater le soin particulier apporté
aux pièces extérieures un sujet plein de
minutes ici regardez
le chantier a commencé depuis plusieurs
mois sous ses bâches blanches l'un des
joyaux de la cathédrale Saint-Julien la
chapelle des anges musiciens ces vitraux
sont en pleine restauration tout comme
sa façade qui a souffert avec le temps
pour se rendre compte il faut monter à
une vingtaine de mètres presque au
sommet de la chapelle on voit bien que
sur cette pierre on a quand même pas mal
de de lacunes on s'aperçoit qu'elle est
un peu friable et qu'elle est qu'elle
est qu'elle est poreuse donc du coup on
va changer tout ce morceau là du réseau
la partie haute s'appelle le réseau de
la pierre cette croix indique que la
pierre va être restaurée ou changer
toutes ne le saurons pas au sol le
directeur des travaux et le chef de
chantier s'appuie sur un scan de
l'édifice c'est lui qui indique ou
travailler ça nous permet c'est un
support qui nous permet de voir
l'avancement de voir où on en est que ce
soit dans la commande ou dans les dans
les changements de pierre
après le repérage vient le temps de
l'extraction et il faut parfois s'armer
de patience pour enlever ces blocs qui
n'ont pas vraiment l'habitude d'être
dérangé des fois on a certaines qui vont
venir en un quart d'heure 20 minutes
comme des fois on va passer une heure à
essayer de
dans le mode d'extraire la pierre
celle-ci comme d'autres passera ensuite
entre les mains des tailleurs de pierre
avant de retrouver son emplacement
originel nous notre rôle c'est que au
moment on déchauffe on voit pas notre
intervention donc on est en lien
vraiment avec l'architecte on va venir
on va venir comprendre ce qui a été fait
ce que nos anciens ont fait pour pour ne
pas dénaturer l'essence même qui a été
vu et imaginé lors de la construction
dans quelques mois les vitraux auront
eux aussi retrouver leur éclats d'antan
2,5 millions d'euros ont été débloqués
par l'étape pour ce chantier à la vue
imprenable sur l'échafaudage il se
murmure d'ailleurs que c'est l'un des
plus beaux buts du monde
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivis on se
retrouve très vite pour une prochaine
édition au revoir à tous et à bientôt
[Musique]